[Music]
on today's show we talked to a couple of
parents who are struggling with identity
and loving themselves and their kids we
talked to a woman whose husband is
addicted to a cell phone in his wreck in
their household and we talked to a
better health therapist on what
counseling is what it's not and how to
do it well stay tuned
[Music]
say you
say me that's how you do that say it for
always what's up this is john delony
with the dr john dolani show
i say this every time i'm glad you're
with us glad you're with us i'm glad you
joined us on this adventure so happy to
see you we got ben on the on the on the
mic
you're the dj it's good to see you man i
like that dj good to see you too that's
what we can call our position the dj i
don't know what it that sounds good and
kelly as always
that song you were singing is actually
from one of my favorite movies see you
say what song is it what what movie
uh from white nights
yeah is it a good movie
it is it's uh gregory heinz and mikhail
brisnikov they're dancers in russia
during like
um
trying to you're turning a little bit
red right now i'm just kidding you're
not
i doubt that trying to pretend you're
having a moment but no no no it's a
great movie
wait no i'll check it out yeah you
should i love a good russian ballet
movie
feels good
that's kind of my jam it's good on my
jam
let's go to the phones before this
thing's getting sideways sideways
danielle in denver colorado what's up
danielle
good morning are you a huge fan of
russian ballet movies
um you've never seen any
danielle so i would have to say no what
i don't even know you anymore come on
never seen one in my life either but i'm
gonna give it i'm gonna give it a whirl
i'm glad same team danielle same team
all right so what's up
how are we doing
yeah so i am
my biggest thing i'm dealing with right
now is my husband and i just had our
fourth and final baby um about three
weeks ago congratulations
thank you so much and he was born via
cesarean as were all of my other three
so we decided the best thing
um for me to do was to get my tubes tied
and um while they were in there might as
well
yeah exactly
and i have been dealing with so much
like grieving like a grieving process
and
um because this chapter of my life has
come to an end of my childbearing years
and i don't know
um
how to grieve and be a mom and a wife at
the same time and if grieving is even
the appropriate word to use
um
with this you know just saying grieving
and pregnancy in the same sentence
sounds ridiculous to me
um
but that's exactly how i'm feeling
so i don't know how i'm supposed to go
forward from here oh man you are awesome
thank you for sharing that have you said
that out loud yet
i've talked to my husband about it
and he's validated my feelings and has
told me that it's absolutely
normal and told me that i'm
doing a great job and you know just 100
validated how i'm feeling yeah um but it
hasn't helped stop feeling this way yes
yes yes
so
i learned this the hard way and then
i've just met with folks over the years
number one well let me back up your
husband sounds like he's awesome he's a
pretty good guy he is
he's amazing good work well done on that
one you got a good one
and he got a good one he got a good one
as well
one of the suckiest things
is so crummy
about grief
and about i'm not gonna suggest you have
postpartum okay i'm just talking about
the post-pregnancy
everything's everywhere
okay when
everything is resettling you got a new
human in a house are your other three
are they young are they small
nine six and three oh my gosh yes yes
it's just
when you think of a nine year old as old
that's when you know
you're tired because nine year olds
aren't old but it just feels like oh
gosh he can wipe himself we're winning
right
so right you've got four young kids four
kids all in single digits let's put it
that way
and now you've got an infant you're not
i mean sleep is all over the place
husband's just trying but god bless them
and there's bottles everywhere and
diapers and all the stuff and then your
three-year-old just misses
mom
and can i get a snack and all that
stuff's happening not to mention any
sort of hormone regulation that's
happening any sort of your body dealing
with oh gosh we're missing organs now
like where did those like all that stuff
yeah your body's recovering from surgery
so it's all there
one of the worst things when you're
dealing with grief and when you're
dealing with that time after
pregnancy
is people will tell you
because they've got awesome souls and
awesome hearts you're doing so great
and in your head you hear that
but your body is telling you that you're
failing and everything's falling apart
and so you feel crazy
and that crazy is exhausting am i onto
something or tell me i'm bonkers
no you you have me tearing up so yeah
so you've got your your mom is like oh
my gosh you're the greatest mom and your
husband is so great and husbands who try
usually have one one one tool in the
tool bag and it is compliments you're
doing great you're kicking butt best mom
ever you're so pretty and you look in
the mirror and you're like i feel like a
train wreck and i feel like i put my
lipstick on with my left hand and i feel
like i'm failing and so now i must be
insane
and then your body responds to the fact
that you're insane with we should hide
we are overwhelmed the last thing i want
to do is have this baby near me because
i'm crazy and but the baby needs me and
now you feel
trapped
and then all of a sudden we start
spiraling
am i on to something
yes
um i don't
yes or no i would say okay tell me how
you're feeling
i don't i know you said you weren't
recommending like postpartum
like depression and that's it it's
definitely i'm not feeling depressed i
am trying
like my hardest
to stay involved with church stuff and
do my so i feel like i'm pushing myself
to do that and once i'm there i feel
good you know being out of the house yes
um so i do feel like getting up good for
you
because i know that helps and especially
going to church that helps feed my soul
as well and so
um
i'm trying to do that kind of stuff and
push myself to do it
so it's just um
so i would say yes and no you were
hitting on some of the stuff because i
am trying to get out and do things you
are so great you're awesome you're
awesome
so here's all here's what grief is grief
is the gap between what we hoped for
or what we expected to happen
in reality
that's all grief is
it's just that gap
i thought my husband was gonna live
forever and there was a car wreck i
thought my dad was gonna always just be
there for me to call and he's 92 and he
passed away i thought
i knew there was going to be a day when
we would just have to be like um 84 kids
is enough how about we just call it good
because now we have a a bus that takes
us to the grocery store
um we knew that day was coming and then
but there's a gap between
yeah that's later and then also it's
now right and so what i would tell you
is
not
be at peace
don't compare your grief
you deserve to feel what you feel
it's real and it's right
yeah and it's okay to say i'm gonna miss
with all of my guts literally
ever
having that incredible bond between me
and another human that nobody else in
this family can share because they were
in my body
i'm gonna miss that
that's okay to be sad about that
it's okay to just be heartbroken about
that
i mean it's nice to hear that it's okay
yeah it's okay
i just like i said i just feel
ridiculous
magic you had a human in you four times
it's magic and then you you guys decided
let's let's call it
let's call it and so yeah grief is not
only natural it's right it's good
and
when time comes then you begin to create
and this is scary and awesome
i get to create who i am next
like what is my new identity because my
identity has been
someone like a baby maker
and now i am a baby razor or i'm a human
maker or i'm whatever i mean you get to
call it whatever you want to call it
but it's just a shift in identity it's
just a new you and those are scary to
leave behind the old times and there was
some magic in those old times and now
we're going to create whatever comes
next
and you co-create that with your husband
you create that with how you feel and
what you want and what you dream about
and
that replanting new fields becomes a
whole new adventure
but man that's not for today
today is just to cherish this beautiful
new baby and to deal with i have a snack
can i have a snack and mommy i diarrhea
it everywhere and
man i'm never gonna have another human
inside me again huh yeah yeah oh it's
both hand
so
um
this may sound crazy and if you've ever
listened to the show you know i
recommend this all the time
it i just heard it over and over and
over as a magic intro solution to grief
i want you
to write a letter to all four of your
kids when they were in your tummy
and i said tummy because i have a
five-year-old and
i still go tt-2 i don't know why i said
that to another adult
what an idiot man i'm such a dummy um
okay yeah i'm gonna go tt right after
the show too by the way
golly in your tummy i want you to write
a letter to those
and remind them talk to them about what
it felt like
when you felt them kick the first time
when you felt
your heartbeat sync up when you were so
excited about what the future was going
to hold
i want you to go back to those places
and write that stuff down one day your
kids when they're old
might read these letters so hang on to
them
okay but it is a way for your brain to
slowly make its way through and your
body
to make its way through that gap
and writing things down gets it out of
our head gets out of our bodies
literally
and it it creates a little bit of
distance on the paper and it becomes
true and it becomes real and when things
become true and real they get out of our
this could happen this is happening to
this happened
and then the magic and now what
but we are not at the now what stage we
are just in the sitting in a stage and
that's okay
good for you for knowing i don't want to
get up but i got to and here's a couple
of things that when i just go there it
makes me things better oh that's awesome
yeah
and thank you
if
you need to tell your husband hey
i know i'm good
how about instead of telling me that i'm
doing a great job you just sit down to
hold my hand
or the best way you can tell me i'm
doing a great job is if i never have to
clean out another bottle ever ever again
ever ever again
and maybe if some of the things as you
feel them as somebody who's trying to
love you well
when it makes your body respond in a
certain way
you don't have to quote unquote take it
you can help somebody who's trying to
love you and say here's a better way you
could love me right now
okay and my wife did that for me it's a
gift actually when we had
when we had our second kid she made me a
list of questions i was not allowed to
ask in the hospital
and it was hilarious and i found myself
starting to ask those questions are you
feeling okay are you doing good are you
i mean i was i mean she just wrote them
all down she's like don't ask me any of
these questions
the answer is i'm gonna just it's gonna
suck for a while then we're gonna have a
baby
and it was awesome but it was a gift and
i was embarrassed and a little bit of
shame that i had asked those when or
someone was born i was about it was hard
when somebody says hey here's a better
way you could love me
but wow then you both get in sync
okay but your grief is good and right
and holy and yours and nobody else's
thank you
is that cool
yeah i i am looking forward to writing
the letters awesome i think that's going
to help me a lot so i thank you for that
you got it and let me know how that goes
you can write all four of them over a
period of a couple of days
and then just write me back my john oh
stupid you're an idiot or write me back
and say no that was actually helpful and
hang on to them and you may have to
write more than one or more than two or
i'm gonna write a letter to that newborn
that i held in the hospital
and maybe it's not a five page letter
maybe it's just a poem or maybe it's
just uh i don't know whatever it happens
to be but you can write letters to these
little to these human beings in their
stages
and it's incredible and it slowly helps
you bridge that gap between what you
expected and what you hoped for
and what is right now
oh you're awesome danielle your kids are
so lucky to have you
and you're not crazy and your grief is
yours and oh my gosh we're rooting for
whatever comes next but that's for later
right now you're in it
and we're in it with you we'll be right
back on the doctor john williams show
[Music]
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john dolone show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work and
time to go see somebody it's way across
town what do i do because i want help
with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with betterhelp because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john doloni show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
hey what's up we are back and listen one
of the most common questions i get from
callers and listeners is what could i
expect from a counseling interaction if
i got the courage to actually call a
counselor if i got the courage to
actually go to counseling to get my
partner and we're going to go to therapy
together what would that be like how do
i know if i'm talking to a good
counselor i know if i'm talking to
someone i just need to get up and walk
away or i need to close my computer
screen and say never again
how do i know what i'm even doing when
it comes to counseling so i reached out
to my friends at betterhelp.com and
y'all know i've got a partnership with
them i love that they provide
counseling and access to therapists
anywhere you happen to be whether in
your car in a parking lot in your home
where at work wherever you happen to be
when you got a screen or a phone they've
got people
licensed clinicians that can um help you
right where you are
i'm sorry i reached out to my friends at
betterhelp and we got connected i got
connected with the head of clinical
operations hasu joe who is a world-class
therapist has agreed to come on the show
and to walk us through what an
interaction with the therapist would
look like so jason how are we doing
great thank you so much what a wonderful
introduction very flattered thank you
humbly
you shouldn't be too humble i i'm in awe
of you you actually do this stuff for a
living i just pretend to be one on the
internets and so you're pretty awesome
so um how we doing how's everything
things are going um it's been an
interesting past couple of years i would
say i think everybody would say that in
response to that kind of question yeah
you know what what's can you paint a
picture what's the world been like for
mental health professionals
uh well i think everybody can start to
imagine what the answer to that is by
answering that question for themselves
what has life been like for you the past
year and a half chances are you've been
stressed out you've been having new
things creating more anxiety for you
maybe your interpersonal relationships
have taken a hit because you're not able
to meet up as much as you would like to
um you're not able to do the same kinds
of activities you're not able to
distract yourself with the same kinds of
things it's been a rough period of time
for everybody
so what a better time to look for a
therapist right but that also means that
these systems that we have in place the
infrastructures that we had before covid
a lot of that stuff had to change and
mental health therapists had to quickly
adapt all while juggling all those life
stressors because we're just people too
and we're also trying to get through
this together with everybody else that's
exactly right and before
um before
the l you know 24 months ago
i was still dealing with all of the
people that i was working with
there were
wild waiting lines there were people who
were apprehensive to go to in-person
counseling there was all sorts of of
barriers there was financial barriers
there's all sorts of barriers for people
to get the help they need and if even if
the barriers were removed there was
still this stigma
it's just this thing we've never done
before i've never gone to talk to
somebody to tell them about what
happened when i was a kid i've never
gone to talk to somebody and say
i've got these crazy thoughts in my mind
or what i think are crazy they often
find out they're not or
me and my partner aren't connecting well
and i don't know what's next all right
so
it's it's a whole thing was new and then
all of a sudden everything got wiped out
and it's all got thrown on the internet
i love it you brought that up my friends
who are clinicians all over the country
have been
you know working from home and
homeschooling and by the way throw your
whole practice online and this i
so many of my colleagues get home bring
it all back into your house all in your
house right and there's just this warmth
and this
i guess a safety that you can create in
an in-person context that's different um
anyway it's been a mess i'm so i want to
just personally thank you for
you and your team and all the mental
health professionals out there trying to
serve a
really um crooked situation lots of
people who are hurting all over the
place so i'm grateful for that
um so here's what i want to do
i want to pretend that i'm a client and
then i'm calling for the first time
and you being a real therapist to me
being a fake one on the internets
or in on this radio show i i want to
call and we can just walk through the
first couple of minutes of what a
interaction between a client and a
therapist would would be like and then
we'll spend some time talking with you
what are some things that a client can
bring to the table in session one
session two session three that would
really
facilitate connection between the
therapist and client and then what are
some things that
a
client should look for somebody who's
hurting who reaches out should look for
as big red flags
sure so i do want to preface by saying
um that initial call that we're about to
role play potentially here that's going
to be a pretty different experience for
somebody that's signing up online
because with the online version you're
not starting with a call
you're starting with answering a few
questions
on an internet intake questionnaire
right so this first call that you do to
reach out to somebody is more for a
traditional practice format which i
think everybody should consider too you
want to figure out what works best for
you right um
so happy to do that and then we can
certainly talk further about what the
like introduction phase looks like on
betterhelp versus other settings great
that's awesome so yeah if you go to
betterhelp it asks you you know what's
your preferences
um gender religious preferences what are
you struggling with what do you think
you're struggling with and it does it
really is a is it greases that
interaction right it gives the therapist
some context and it gives it actually
helps when i went through the
questionnaire myself it gave me some
context for helping me distill down what
i'm actually calling what actually is
going on in my heart and mind right
which is great
all right cool so let's pretend um
uh james will you come over and make a
phone noise
bring br yeah because we're seven two
jesse um all right
so bring bring
um
hi my name is john and i am reaching out
to a counselor for the first time
hi john thanks so much for getting in
touch with me my name is hesu and i am a
licensed therapist um
so i'm guessing you're reaching out
because you're going through something
do you think you can tell me in a couple
of sentences what you're looking for
support with
i'm not great at distilling things down
to a couple sentences but for the sake
of this role play i will try i am
um
i've had a
great professional year
my
family is my marriage is doing great my
kids i mean it's been hard i got little
ones and so getting in and out of school
and all that it's been tough but on the
whole when i look objectively
at what's
at the
data points in my life objectively
things are going fine they're going well
actually
it feels like there is something beneath
the data points
that is still churning maybe like a um a
duck on the water the the things on top
are still they're going well we're still
moving forward
but my body is beginning to tell me hey
we are i'm reaching capacity i'm running
out of gas and i don't know what to do
with that when the data point when the
things i'm doing are working
if you will quote unquote with air
quotes
i don't know what to do with that
low-level burn uh it feels like
anxiousness it feels like kind of a rise
of
i don't know man my body's trying to
tell me something and i'm not doing a
good job of hearing it
i mean what i'm hearing is
kind of a
distinct separation between how you're
thinking you should be feeling and what
you're actually feeling inside right
you're like looking at your life
and seeing that things are pretty good i
should be feeling better so why don't i
is it am i do you think that i'm
understanding kind of what you're
sharing with me here yes you just nailed
it yes ma'am
yeah so
you know i think that um it's definitely
worth it for us to book a first session
and we can talk a little bit more about
some of these things going on to help
you start to learn to identify exactly
what it is that's going on so then we
can start working together
collaboratively to figure out some kind
of course of treatment
to get you feeling better right to get
your insides and your outsides to match
and to feel like you're living
authentically and and that's one of my
big focuses is to get you to feel like
you're navigating and existing in this
world in a way that makes sense and
feels safe for you
so if that all sounds good for you
i'd love to move forward in scheduling
that first session and i i like the idea
but i want one quick question for you
when you say treatment i think of iv
bags and
therapy
what do you mean by treatment that
freaks me out a little bit yeah
that's a good question to have and i
think it's very important for us to
you know be mindful that there is a
connection between medical model and
therapy but at the same time it's not
the same thing which each individual is
going to be different
when you look at the medical model they
may have
standards of care and protocols
processes manualize treatments
you know use this medication for these
kinds of symptoms it doesn't always end
up looking that simple or black and
white in therapy so i use this word
treatment to really encapture
nothing like a medication course because
that's not something that i can do
that's something i can help you explore
but in talk therapy this treatment word
it's really focusing on
the the work that we're going to do
collaboratively through discussion
through homework assignments and i'm not
talking about like writing essays
between sessions but it could look like
having you
tune in and identify certain feeling
words that we'll discuss during sessions
throughout the week so you can
incorporate some of the things that
we're learning in your real life because
at the end of the day how much you and i
speak as therapist and client is a very
very small percentage of your real life
and what's more important is practicing
the skills that you and i are going to
learn together outside in your real life
outside of the session so treatment
really captures
this you know intentional
focus with both of us working towards
meeting your goals right treatment kind
of
helps us understand that we're doing
something actively for symptom relief
for increased insight for meeting your
goals awesome so yeah it's treatments
that path we're going to take to get
okay i love that that's awesome all
right well thank you that's dude that's
that's a good entry so
if you're listening to the show here a
couple of things that she did so well
one she validated my questions she'd
make me feel stupid and if i asked if i
you know what's treatment she didn't say
i didn't know what treatment is everyone
knows a treatment like you validated my
questions which i appreciated um
you asked me to drive
and let you know what was going on in my
life and not i didn't you didn't answer
the phone look at my chart and start
telling me what you thought was wrong
with me you didn't open with a diagnosis
it's a probably better way to say that
um and you're really inviting and warm
and so i'm grateful for that thank you
just talking to you for two minutes made
my blood pressure go down a little bit
so i'm i'm grateful for that oh we're
glad to hear that um so maybe we should
schedule a session
trust me i think you're probably right
um
over your years of doing this i mean
you're the clinical director of a major
national um mental health organization
in your years of meeting with clients
what are a couple of things that you
have noticed really assist
with
getting things going
versus what are some client behaviors
that make things challenging as a
counselor
yeah um well first i got to call this
out it's it's really weird hearing
myself described as like this leader of
a run-out company you know i started
with the company when we were really
really tiny and i want to put that
message out there we're still a
tight-knit group of people a bit larger
now but we're all just a group of people
that's trying our best to provide help
to a bunch of people out there that's
right um but coming back to your
question
you know i think
it's important to remember that your
therapist is professionally trained to
deal with something we call resistance
resistance is everybody's natural
inclination to withdraw or shy away from
things that make us feel uncomfortable
things that would ask us to revisit
painful memories or the past a lot of
therapy is about processing that stuff
externalizing those things so that it's
not rotting inside of you anymore
um and so
this thing of like
what can a client do to make sure that
their therapist is thinking that they're
a good client like first i don't want
anyone to think that they have to
perform or they have to do anything
specifically yes they're there in the
chair in that moment to be there in the
here and now and that's one of my
focuses and you'll find that therapists
are very very diverse in terms of how
they approach clients and how they think
about them but for me one of those
underlying goals that i have for me and
my client is to get the client to be
better about paying attention to what's
right in front of them the present
moment a lot of mental health challenges
come from dwelling in the past or
freaking out about the future in which
case you're never able to really sit and
enjoy what's right in front of you
um
so
really i want clients to know that just
be you and i know that's easier said
than done
but trying to let go of any assumptions
that you need to do something to appear
a certain way is going to be really
helpful
um challenging yourself to answer
questions honestly and listen when you
first start therapy you might feel
overwhelmed with questions your
therapist is going to ask you a ton of
things and if you're feeling like it's
too overwhelming it's even a good idea
to ask your therapist to slow down
your therapist is there to follow your
lead and ultimately walk hand in hand
with you rather than take charge and
take reigns of your life you are the
expert of your life yeah so yeah so i
i'd be prepared to speak honestly and
and sometimes honesty can be painful and
it's okay to mention that too in the
moment let your therapist know when
something is too hard yeah
that's beautiful what
that's the number one piece of advice i
always give somebody when they say i'm
about to go to counseling what should i
do
i'll tell them
don't go unless you're gonna tell the
truth
and telling the truth is gonna hurt it's
gonna be hard sometimes
and um
don't perform like this is the one this
might be the first time in your whole
life you can go drop your shoulders and
just say this is the way i feel right
now and
we just don't have those places in our
society anymore i don't know if we ever
did but um
yeah what a gift so what's a couple of
red flags that some if somebody reaches
out to their you know they go to a local
counselor somewhere
and
what's what are some red flags or what
as a clinical director what are some
things you make sure you instill in the
therapists that work on your team
in the service of other people
well safety is always number one safety
trumps everything so
that's something that's something that i
think of as a therapist so my
translation for clients out there are
potential clients listening to this and
remember i was a client before i ever
became a therapist so i know what that
feels like too and i continue to put
myself in that seat
if you don't feel safe with this person
that's the biggest red flag it could
just be vibes it could be that you're
not connecting with them but ultimately
if you don't feel safe with this person
how can you expect yourself how can you
force yourself
to really become intimate and vulnerable
with somebody that you don't feel good
with that you don't feel safe with so
tune in to your feelings because they're
really important here
this relationship you're about to enter
with a therapist granted it's not going
to be the same as a friendship or a
loving
significant other this person is a
professional this is a professional
business relationship at the end of the
day but you're still two humans and if
there's no connection
i think that's something that you should
listen to your gut about and that can be
very
you know challenging for some people
because it took so long to find this
first person in the first place but i
think you owe it to yourself and your
healing journey and the process that
you're taking ownership of to find the
right provider for you
so that's the number one thing
to look out for is if you don't feel
safe that's a red flag
you know if if the therapist even says
anything that
maybe you feel like is
a blind spot that's something to pay
attention to i wouldn't say that that's
a reason to change therapists but you
want to make sure that you
feel comfortable with this person's
approach
so you can come prepared to your first
initial sessions with questions you can
ask questions about their approach you
can ask questions about what to expect
you can ask questions about how they
generally structure sessions what you
can expect out of this whole thing so
when you first go in there for that
first session you know i said to expect
that they're going to ask a lot of
questions you should also feel
comfortable and know that it is your
right to ask a bunch of questions and
basically interview this person to see
if they're the right match for you too
obviously signs of abuse if you are
feeling like triggered by this person
and they're starting to replicate things
in your life that make you feel unsafe
it just comes back to that safety piece
again
um
yeah and then you know if
you want to think about logistical
things if you're not going to be able to
make your schedule line up with what
this therapist has available that's a
big thing that you want to pay attention
to because you don't want to enter
something knowing that you're not going
to be able to meet on a consistent basis
in the way that makes sense for
accountability and learning new skills
yeah don't don't make your life more
stressful in just trying to get to your
appointment i don't even thought about
that but yeah that's fantastic right
right yeah so you want to ask about
scheduling logistics stuff if this is a
place that you need to travel to if
you've chosen in-person options think
about how this fits into your lifestyle
and your day and rush hour and all those
things
transportation is that an issue for you
so these are things now you're thinking
about on your own not necessarily
thinking about with a therapist but all
these logistics are also part of it
um you know in therapy the dropout rate
is quite high and i think the reason
being or there's plenty of reasons but
some of the reasons i can think of is
that it's just too hard to make it fit
into the busy lifestyle of a working
professional yes after my full-time job
how am i supposed to get over there or
maybe it's that this therapist works
also traditional business hours which is
pretty common how can i get over there
during my work so
or i got kids to pick up or i got food
yeah yeah i always tell folks who tell
me that i don't have time to go
um or i don't have the money to go
i often will say
you'll end up there
if you want to go on your terms i think
it's worth that time you don't have time
not to go
or this is reminding me of like some
kind of proverb i heard where we spend
so much of our youthful prime
working for money and not having time
right at this time of our lives we have
money and energy but we don't have the
time now later in your life if you
haven't been taking care of yourself you
may have a bunch of money saved up you
may now have a bunch of time but you
don't have energy or health and so it's
this thing where you want to balance all
these things in your life so you're
thinking about and taking care of your
future but also your present person
um are you healthy now and do you have
ways to carve out time for yourself
because if you don't that's an issue for
your future absolutely absolutely
absolutely well listen jesus i'm so so
grateful for you um
just taking the time to to call and or
and and walk through what just somebody
who's actually practicing mental health
care out there i'm grateful for your
expertise and your service to our local
communities it's just such a gift
and thank you for giving us a couple of
pointers on how to enter that space and
just being a warm presence for me i'm
telling you just just that gentle
conversation i speak to james and kelly
most of the time and most of their
interactions with me are so ruthless and
just your just your gentleness and
kindness is such a gift and your
expertise you you got a great
combination of of
bold expertise and strength and warmth
and so i'm really grateful for you
um thank you so much john thank you for
having me you betcha all right hey we'll
be right back on the dr john dolone show
we are back
with seth in the slc salt lake city
what's up seth
how's it going john dude we are rocking
onto the break of dawn this morning how
about you very good i'm i'm very good
dude i just got back from salt lake city
what a beautiful beautiful city i was
there a couple of times this month
i didn't even stop by and say hi we did
i hung out you were too busy
whatever playing video games whatever
hey that is a beautiful city
stunning yeah
yeah there's a lot to like about it it's
just i i mean
you're more than welcome to visit more
often john
well thank you they asked me to leave
but i appreciate you i'm just kidding
they didn't especially i i just the more
i travel the more this country is so big
and so beautiful and there's so many
awesome people it just it's incredible
but great community there man so what's
up brother how can i help
so i have two sons one of them is two
years almost two years old the other one
is four my older one has kind of been my
shadow his whole life um anytime i'm off
work he's with me my younger son i just
don't have that same connection with
them and i i don't i don't know how to
how do i make room for one without
pulling away from the other one
that's a great question man
so have you tried this and you felt like
you were pulling away from one tell me
about that
yeah well this so this is going to sound
um crazy right have you ever heard this
show before
uh yeah yeah we're all crazy it's cool
so what's up so i was i was sitting
on the floor with my younger son we were
reading a book together and everything
was fine when my older son came up and
sat down my younger son just like got up
and walked away but then he turned back
and looked at me
like almost like i had betrayed him does
that make sense he's like he doesn't
feel like there's space for him and it
kind of broke my heart yes yes
absolutely
um
oh there's so much there
so much there
you know who broke your heart
you know
not your two-year-old
don't give your two-year-old that kind
of power
no i don't okay here's why they're two
and there's a reason why as a society
we've been like you know what we
shouldn't let two-year-olds buy beer not
a good idea
and uh we shouldn't let two-year-olds
drive or operate heavy machinery or
smoke marijuana like there's a whole
bunch of things we've said two-year-olds
can't do but we give them access to our
souls
and they say things like i don't like
you daddy and it destroys us
or they they give a look to us and we
interpret that look as
you betrayed me father
i'll remember this
and i will kill you in your sleep you
scoundrel i mean like we say this crap
to ourselves so duh but hey i do it too
man i do it too i told my wife that i uh
i'll be careful i tell us i told my wife
the other day
like literally our daughter doesn't like
me
and she looked at me like i was she's
like yes she does you're annoying and
she doesn't like to be around annoying
but she really likes you
and my wife was right so all that to say
is this man
i'm just smiling so big because i've
been right where you are
where i feel like that
you betrayed me father i
felt that so bad give me give me another
time give me another time
well
he
the younger one
as long as it's just him and i he's
totally fine with kind of playing right
but then any time my older son comes up
and wants to play around as well he just
kind of
goes away like he doesn't want to stay
and play with the two of us me and my
older son and i'm sorry as a three you
know he doesn't want to play his three
he wants to play kind of one-on-one and
him and his brother have a great
relationship
but it just to me
the only way i can describe it is to he
he just doesn't feel like he has space
if my older son is there
and i would say that you're putting a
lot of
words into his head
that's true lots of thoughts and
feelings and emotions
it may just be things are loud it may be
that dad acts different when brother
shows up
and i i for whatever reason your kid
feels uncomfortable about that
but articulating there's just enough
space for me here that's a lot to put in
the head of a two-year-old
so i it probably actually goes back to
one of my biggest fears about having a
second kid was that i wouldn't be able
to
uh
you know the relationship just with my
second is so much different from my
first because i already have a first yes
one of my one of my great friends man
he's one of the greatest men i've ever
met his name's brad he's awesome guy and
i remember
man he was one of the first one of our
little gang to have kids and his
daughter man he
loved that girl he was incredible dad
just awesome dad
and
they were talking about having a second
kid and i never forget he mentioned to
me and it had never occurred to me until
he said it
i don't understand how i could possibly
love
somebody as much as i love this my
daughter
and so i don't know that i won't have a
second kid because i that wouldn't be
fair
because there's no way it competes with
this
and so what i would tell you is that
same fear that you're expressing there
you're put it out into the world and now
you're looking for it everywhere where
am i not adding up where am i not loving
enough where am i not doing this right
you hear what i'm saying
yeah yeah i uh this is not how i
expected this
well i want i want you to flip this
whole thing around
you're gonna love these kids differently
and you're gonna love these kids a lot
and my daughter needs different types of
connection and interaction than my son
does
my son loves to hug
my daughter loves fighting i don't
understand it but it is
awesome it's just so different
like i will come home from work and my
i'll say hey come here hank and he'll
come over and we'll hug i just it's a
good 15 30 second hug
and then i will set my backpack down and
my daughter will square up with me
and she'll say are you ready and she's
five i'm like i get i guess we're gonna
have our welcome home fist fight here we
go you know what i mean
it's just this chaotic
like a hurricane of hair and
hands
and it's awesome and then we hug and
then it goes our kid we're going to love
them differently
and so here's two things we can do
the first thing is this
ask yourself honestly am i annoyed by my
my younger son
does he annoy me
do i feel bothered by him
those are the feelings that i want you
to root out
and those aren't things he's doing to
you that's not the fundamental
attribution error when you get in his
head and you pretend you know what he's
thinking and why he's doing things you
can't do that
get inside your own head and say it
actually kind of annoys me when he comes
around
or
he he just doesn't play like my other
kid does
i want you to root those things out
because your young son will feel that
he'll absorb that stuff
and i want you to be honest about how do
i connect with my kid and this is the
pot talking to the kettle here brother
cause i'm learning this in real time
right now um
how do i connect with each one of my
kids and how do i give each one of my
kids their own time
and
they've got to learn to play with one
another and me at the same time because
we're gonna have lots of family trips
we're gonna have lots of times and we're
all going hunting together and we're all
going fishing and we're gonna have times
when we're all gonna go
play family or play house or whatever it
is we're gonna do there
um but it's what's both and
and if your son
decides when your other son shows up
that he doesn't want to participate
i want you to grab his two-year-old
little hands
and say
daddy would love it if you stayed and
played with us
daddy wants you to be a part of this
it's more fun for us to play when you're
with us
and then he's free to go if he wants to
so i don't want him to ever leave
without a
hey i want you to know that we would
have more fun if you were here
and i don't want him to feel forced
trapped into a situation that for
whatever reason he doesn't want to be a
part of right now
and i would s
for the best you can
don't overthink an interaction with a
two-year-old
[Laughter]
don't let me rephrase let me rephrase
that
two-year-olds are brilliant and
intuitive
and so if a kid doesn't feel safe and
they walk away be it be attuned to that
don't over intellectualize a
two-year-old how about that
okay
don't have academic conversations with
somebody who is less than 36 months old
lean into the things that he loves
invite your four-year-old into those
things and let your foil do things that
maybe are different are your boys way
different from each other
yes yeah yeah yeah so give him some
private
connection time
and then someday say hey we're all gonna
color because it may just be when the
four-year-old brother comes we all end
up playing soccer and the two-year-old
just wants a color
or the two-year-old wants to play soccer
and the four-year-old like all soccer
balls go away we just saw color so be
attuned to those kind of things but just
be intentional about last time we played
this today we're going to play this
and if your four-year-old throws a fit
and says well i'm not doing that
you do the same thing with him i'd love
it if you were here it's more fun to
color when you're with us
but if you want to go play feel free
and they're going to learn autonomy and
what they're going to learn is oh i'm
making the choice to leave this
situation dad's not kicking me out here
[Music]
i like it that sound good
yes thank you very much hey sir you're
just john brother just john and
you're a good dad man
i wish every
couple of little boys had an old man
like you who was just trying to
love them the best he knew how good for
you man good for you
we don't let two-year-olds buy
cigarettes
we don't let them hurt our feelings
one of the same i can't wait to see the
internet comments on that one we'll be
right back on the dr john dolone show
y'all know there are lots of things that
make me nuts but one thing makes me more
nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too i love living in a
new home but i gotta be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you've got an expert in
a team who have your back listen if
you're about to buy a home and make a
big change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple h
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in nmls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right uno mas let's go out to
amarillo texas 806 and talk to beth
what's going on beth
hi dr john i'm super excited to talk to
you today i am equally excited to talk
to you how are you
i'm doing good feeling really optimistic
about our call hopefully i'll learn
something new well i'm optimistic that i
won't screw this up for you and
whoever it is you're calling about so
what's up
okay so i'm wondering how i can help my
husband see that his phone use is
impacting or like hindering our
relationship and his relationship with
our kids
you should text him
that was a fantastic joke that might
help
it probably would help so tell me what's
going on
okay so i'll give you kind of like a
rundown of what our days look like um
recently and this isn't always but just
here more recently he goes to work and
when he comes home it's just facing the
phone until pretty much until we go to
bed
what's he doing on that phone
so
he doesn't have a great separation
between
work
and home which is fine because he can't
always have that with what he does so i
understand that but
what's he do
he's in real estate he does a lot of
different
real estate stuff just he flips houses
sells houses
has airbnbs so there's a lot of stuff
that kind of he's got he's just got it
going on
yeah it's
it's good job all right so
he's got it going on he gets home he
gets off of work but he's never off of
work he just moves his body to a new
physical location
pretty much and it happens to plop right
in the middle of you and how old are
your kids
our kids are three and four months old
oh jeez
so
so i'm
yeah i am i am i've lived this life
i was your husband
and i lost
years with my family
to a stupid cell phone
i lost him and
i can get and get emotional if i let
myself
because they're gone i can never ever
have them back
and there will come a moment when the
light bell that the light bulb will go
off
that one more
solving a dishwasher issue at one of the
bed and breakfast one of the
whatever it is yeah
wasn't worth
losing my three-year-old to my
five-year-old to my seven-year-old to my
nine-year-old
that's what i cashed it in for dealing
with a with a
a lawn mower issue dealing with a
drywall issue all right
been there right so been there
so tell me about how you've tried to
talk to him about it
well
the issue that we're kind of having
recently is
he's on his phone and it i can't tell
the difference between him just
scrolling through facebook and him you
know typing out an email like from my
perspective i can't tell the difference
and just so you're
not no you're not crazy there is no
difference
okay none
especially to those in relationship or
trying to be in relationship around a
person who is addicted to their cell
phone
there is no difference i don't care why
you're on it you just are
you're just not with me
yeah
you're not present with us you are here
and not here can i tell you something
bananas there's actually some research
on this
okay when somebody is
at work when they're gone there's a
physical separation in a
your body knows they're gone
when they come back
in your presence but they're not present
there's parts of your brain that
recognizes they are there and there's
parts of your brain that recognizes they
are not there
and it makes you crazy
i'm feeling it it makes you nuts and it
makes your kids bonkers because they see
dad there but dad's not there and our
brains aren't designed for that
our brains are not here
unplugged here plugged
plugged in
so
when you talk to him he says no i've got
to deal with this tell me tell me what
his responses are
so
unfortunately like when he's on his
phone and i try to spark a conversation
he just absolutely doesn't hear me and
that's one of the main issues that i'm
having is
i can ask a question three times before
he ever looks up to acknowledge me
or same with my children he'll they'll
ask my three-year-old to ask him the
same question three times before he ever
looks up and like says anything um
i think his he just is self-proclaimed
one-track minded which i just kind of
like it's crap
like you hear me
yeah you know so let me ask you this
what is he hiding from in your marriage
i don't think it's necessarily anything
within our own marriage if i'm being
honest i think he's just tired
i think he's saying that he's hiding
from something
um and i'm not saying he's having an
affair that's not what i'm saying
i'm saying
whatever he comes home to
is he is decided
or
actually is or a
toxic combination of both those
he can't handle it
and so this phone
is a drink and another drink and another
drink this phone is a joint
this phone is a
six pack of tall boys this phone is a
bag of gummy candies
it is a way to numb out and disappear
i'm fulfilling my role my body is here
nobody can say i'm i'm not present or i
don't care about my kids
but i cannot i'm hiding in my own house
yeah
um
i don't know i think
truthfully before we had our second son
we did a lot of
you know
our happy moments we're sitting down and
really getting to talk to each other and
kind of tell each other what's going on
in our days and
you know we would do that when we would
take our
our oldest to the park and then when we
had uh our second son things kind of got
flipped upside down he was sick for a
few months and we just kind of went into
survival mode
and i think we've pulled back from a
little bit of that conversational
intimacy but then
that also
kind of trickles down into
physical intimacy as well so maybe it
has to do with that
so
physical intimacy and relational
intimacy are one and the same they're
intimately linked
and
they work they're recursive
they work together and sometimes couples
get on either side of those things like
i feel more relational when we're having
sex and i feel more relational when
we're
chit-chatting which leads to more sex
which leads to more relational right
people approach that thing differently
and it's at different times and
different seasons and all that stuff
i would guess your husbands never got
out of survival mode
and when you got fight fight or freeze
after a couple of months of fighting or
of sprinting around everywhere
frantically
at some point your body just says i
can't keep doing this so i'm unplugging
and there probably has never been a
conversation a time a family retreat uh
y'all two go spend a half day together
where one of you has the courage to say
we just went through hell
and we made it
and here we are
and now what
yeah and if you don't have that
conversation
your body will be trying to solve for
that disconnection for years
until somebody at work texts you and
your heart starts beating faster again
for the first time and all of a sudden
you find yourself in a situation you
never intended to be in
or
he just
completely unplugs from everything
till you and the kids create all lives
and then he just doesn't have to i mean
he just goes off to his thing
right which i know like that would be
not at all what he wants like he
literally has a heart of gold absolutely
you know and
i know his picture for what he would
want his family life to be like and it's
just not what it is right now there you
go there you go and so
i want to look at
yes the phone is the issue right now
but the phone is the issue there's a
deeper issue underneath the phone which
is
you don't feel connected in your
marriage anymore you
beth you you and your husband haven't
reset control alt deleted after your
little boy was born he was sick and you
all went through
um chaos and chaos and chaos
you often said
y'all are still sprinting
yeah
and he has found himself in a world he
doesn't love in a situation not not that
he doesn't love you do you want to say
but he's found himself in a world that
he doesn't want
and he's trapped
he's an addict
and you may have heard me say this but
all addiction is when your anxiety
alarms are going off your depression
alarm is going awesome you crawl up in
the kitchen and your smoke detector's
going off and you just take a pillow and
you duct tape it around the pillow i
mean around the alarm just so it'll be
quiet
and that's all that phone is
and he found himself with a
four-year-old and a young kid or
two-year-old young kid and he doesn't
know how to engage with him and he found
himself with a wife that he remembers
deep talks with and he remembers
crazy bonker sex with and and now it's
just y'all are running a business
together and he just goes down the phone
yeah
and those things turn into spirals and
all of a sudden you find yourselves two
inches apart on the couch and two
thousand miles away from each other
right
right
so here's what i'll tell you the worst
time to have a conversation about the
cell phone is when he's holding the cell
phone
which is hard because he's always
holding himself up
here's what um
here's what i want you to do
this is going to take some bravery on
your part it's going to be a risk
i want you to tell him
i need to put the phone down and hold
both of my hands and look at me in my
eyes
and he'll go oh gosh
[Music]
have him do that
and if you won't do it you're gonna have
to write this down on a piece of paper
and a letter
nah he'll do it okay
say
i have booked us
a night at a hotel
and i have or i have booked us a at some
restaurant here in amarillo
i've got child care for us
we have two little ones
we're disconnected and i want to talk
about what comes next in our marriage
will you please join me and here's the
rule about this tr this time together
no phones none zero
okay
okay
and if he says well just can't we i want
you to tell him i want to talk about the
future of our marriage
and i want to have no phones when we
have this conversation
and i need you to say it like that so he
feels you and hears you
okay and
let's be real there's a part of you that
is scared that you are losing him am i
right
yeah there's a part of you that is
scared because he's going away like
you're holding sand and he's just
falling through your fingers
and if he can't hear you he needs to
hear honey i'm scared about what
tomorrow's going to look like for us
because right now
you're more interested in your phone
than you are your wife and kids
and i'm asking you to come spend some
time with me so we can talk about what
comes next without a phone
and in the meantime
i know it's a pain in the butt but i
want you to get some child care you all
go spend a half day together but i want
you to write down your concerns your
thoughts your dreams what are you
missing
it can't just get somewhere and be like
dude you gotta deal with that phone
cause he'll deal with the phone for a
month and he'll turn into somebody who
has one too many drinks or is always out
with this what what it'll turn into
another thing not actually addressing
this there you go issue okay
i would love for you to go back and say
we went into survival mode when our
youngest one was sick
and
i miss you
what does it look like
for us to
start sleeping together again what does
it look like for us to start having
chit chats again when you get home
what's it look like for you to come home
and from 5 to 9 pm there are no cell
phones
and you have somebody else that can take
that call i'd rather spend the money
than lose my husband what's it look like
for you to
go play with our kids with no phone
but i need this phone to be that will
come up but that's not the that's not
the root the root is
he's exhausted he's checked out
and you saying i want you back and he
may say i thought you checked out and so
i got scared and so i checked out that's
probably what will happen and you'll
have to hear some hard stuff too
probably is that fair
yeah which i'm
that's another reason that i'm a little
bit
hesitant to bring stuff up with him is
because
he never complains about anything that
i'm falling behind on like i feel so
guilty trying to point out something
that
he's doing that
impact or like that's not my favorite
because i don't i never want to be the
type of wife
that is nagging and i don't want him to
feel like i am
and he never complains about
anything that i do and i know i'm not
perfect
and so i don't want it to be this
one-sided well i'm just doing what she
says to keep her happy
and i it would go a long way for him to
hear from you
like what do you want hon
what do you want this like let's paint a
picture of this thing
we've got two little ones now they're
both safe they're both healthy they're
both doing okay we get to decide what
this marriage looks like
and four hours on a phone until you
collapse from the tv that just seems
like a like a
what a waste of the one reckless
precious life we got
yeah
and i'll tell you two things number one
you're right nagging does never solves
anything
but choose guilt over resentment every
time you've heard me say that i'll say
it a million more times
choose guilt
choose hey i need you i'm missing you
over saying nothing because you're going
to say nothing long enough
and then you're all of a sudden you're
going to say it's going to turn to well
screw you man
yeah
and then it's hard to come back from
that
and by the way nobody's perfect in a
relationship nobody's perfect
and it's not a competition well he never
complained so i can never complain no
i think complaining is a waste of time
telling somebody i miss you and i love
you and that phone is between us that's
not complaining going get off your phone
get off your phone get off your phone
that's complaining
you know what i mean
and once you have this hard conversation
once you'll go out and have breakfast
together and you come back and he pops
that phone up
he's making a choice
and that choice is that little five inch
screen over his wife and his children
and that's why this whole thing's a risk
it's scary
because he could choose that phone he
could choose well i'm gonna buy houses
i'm flipping stuff whatever he could
keep choosing and choosing and choosing
and that's why this whole thing is uh
you're way out on a limb here but i
don't think that's the kind of guy he is
from what you've told me
i want him to hear i miss you
and i'm not done fighting for you i'm
going all in on you
let's get this thing back and not only
now let's don't get this thing back
let's build something new scratch that i
shouldn't have said that i hate when
people say that we're not getting
anything back we're gonna build
something new we're gonna build
something incredible
let's do this together
you're awesome beth he's lucky to have
you let's
have these conversations and let me know
how that breakfast goes i can't wait to
hear about it i can't wait to hear about
it ah you're awesome all right as we
wrap up today's show this
is for me amigo
armando
i love you armando this is off the
august and everything after record
one of the greatest records of all time
literally
counting crows in the song is perfect
blue buildings and it goes like this
just down the street from your hotel
baby i stay at home with my disease
ain't this position familiar darling
while the monkeys do what they see help
me stay awake i'm falling
down on virginia and lyloma where i got
friends who will care for me you got an
attitude of everything i ever wanted i
got an attitude of need so help me stay
awake i'm falling
asleep in perfect blue buildings beside
the green apple c gonna get me a little
oblivion baby
try to keep myself away from me
armando that's a good tune brother it's
awesome see you soon on the dr john
dolani show